you know get down like 29 cops had me
and they sat me down
you're being charged you're kidnapping
one kidnapping two
aggravated robbery uh second-degree
burglary oh boy
and and some other [__] stupid
[__] felony and i'm like
kidnapping i've been kidnapped nobody so
at that point i was so coked up
and so delusional that i was going in
there with the superhero defense
what are you talking about i took the
coke off the streets
you should give me a cape that's street
value like eighty thousand i took it off
the [__] street where is it on fire
i did save you guys a job the taxpayers
that was my defense that was in the back
of my mind i'm gonna go in there and
tell them i was working like a superhero
for who for myself me and [__] gotham
city
i swear to god guys that was the
original defense i had so
they set me down they asked me they want
to talk to me and i'm like sure i'll
talk to you
you wave the attorney i go yeah [__] the
attorney then they start telling me that
i was involved in the killing of some
[__] guy
and then i i kidnapped some other guy
and i'm like whoa whoa what's kidnapping
i never called nobody in my life and
asked for a ransom
and they're like kidnapping is when you
take somebody from one room into another
room
against their will so next time you take
your girlfriend go get in there i'm
gonna [__] you in the ass
that's kidnapping if you really get down
to it you know what i'm saying
don't find out after the fact that's a
[__] in the jail cell what are
you here for i pushed my girlfriend in
the other room i thought i was on the
[__] ass kid napping
gotta be careful you gotta pay attention
there's loopholes in this [__]
the forefathers knew what they were
doing
so they're just throwing this [__] at me
and i'm just talking about [__] the
kennedy assassination i'm just
i don't know what you're talking about
were you there and i'm trying to [__]
direct them so
i'm not there anywhere nothing like do
you know him i met him at very
like uh very very what's that word
subtle
i was very like uh and they go [__] it
you got 50 000 bail cash because you
don't know nobody out here
plus all these chargers get in there and
they sat me in there for a [__] month
a month but it was great it was boulder
county jail you ain't never been to jail
until you've been to boulder county
they let you keep your clothes they give
you cigarettes you can stay up till two
they got cable tv
carpeting are you [__] kidding me
homeless people would go to boulder and
break a window just to go to jail in the
winter
croissants [__] therapy massages
candles rock yoga come on now that's a
[__] summer camp for some
[__]
they had a unit like you got promoted up
the system by the time i left i was in
red i was wearing my own clothes
[__] watching tv till three in the
morning hbo in boulder county jail not
no more
they got hip and now you're in a [__]
tin can with a black and white tv
no cigarettes this is when jail was
jailed was a [__] paradise
you didn't mind i'm [__] getting
locked up for a week [__] and i'll catch
up on my reading
you went to the library you know it
wasn't bad i get into that and i had
been in trouble before
i had been in little county jails
overnight but this was a stint you know
and i'm in there sitting there
and the in-laws that [__] hated me
she finally went to him
and said to him you know he got in
trouble and he said let me go talk to
him and if he tells me the truth i'll
let him out i'll bail him out
the father came bailed me out i told him
the truth what happened
he bailed me on and we became the best
of [__] friends but i still had this
thing hanging over me
so a week after i get out like a month
later they said to me all right your
first deal is 12
[__] years and it's violent so you're
going to do
12 [__] years so my first attorney's
name was sunny he was a good guy
but he was basically the da's puppet so
when he came to me and told me 12
[__] uh years i was like you're
[__] crazy my mother
and all the gangsters in my hometown had
a lawyer in jersey city called sam
i remember being a kid with my mother
and gone there my mother was a bookmaker
and he was plain and simple another old
school jew yarmulke diamonds
the whole [__] thing no shirt on
eating a [__] pastrami sandwich
that's how rich he was mustard on his
face he didn't give a [__] you know what
i'm saying
he would give you like a jew menu here
you go this is the deal all right
you got call for book making two it's
two to four years
i get you out for a year it's gonna cost
you two hundred thousand
six months gonna cost you fifty thousand
and whatever and he just break it down
for you probation's gonna cost you 200
he'd just break a menu down thank you
for coming think about it get back to me
in 30 days it was no nothing
he knew the judges he knew the [__]
da's he so i called him first it cost
1500 just to talk to him on the [__]
phone
you know i'm like are you [__]
kidding me all the money my mother gave
you all those years [__]
so i called him up and he's like this is
what you got to do you're in both those
are white people
i can't show up there cost you 2 million
for me to show up there those are white
people will scare them
he goes you gotta get yourself a white
gangster
he goes go see this guy at the at the
boulder law school
he's a good friend of mine his name is
james mexican dude
i paid like a thousand bucks to talk to
this guy this guy just broke it down for
me it was doug
there was a machine gun involved you're
doing time
you're doing time so if the witness
disappears
no matter what plans you may have you're
doing time because the d.a will take it
over so you make the witness because my
plan was to make the witness disappear
so he couldn't testify but they didn't
give a [__] the guys tidwell had already
rolled
he was in jail his bail was higher than
mine and he mysteriously got let out
on a bail thing because when they took
him to jefferson county he owed 18
on some ticket he paid the 18 they let
him out on the clerical era
so here i am hanging out there fighting
for myself and they're coming to me
and i remember i got into it sonny one
day i'm like are you [__] crazy 12
years and i was just stalling
because sam told me to stall maybe the
victim would just disappear on his own
he won't testify
stall this [__] pay the attorney
to stall it make people forget their
memory
all this [__] it's in your defense so he
goes take that attorney
wait before the preliminary hearing and
fire him and that's another [__] two
months then you decide on an attorney
and that's another two months
he goes you'll milk this [__] so
james was the one that sat me down told
me you're gonna do time no matter what
so if you pay a hundred thousand gonna
do time or you pay fifty dollars you're
gonna do time so just do the time find
yourself a
medium attorney go in there with a white
dude and he gave me this guy his name
was sam
and when he would answer the phone he go
hello this is sam
and when i went to see him he had a bow
tie and a little [__] elvis pomp i'm
like oh no
and the guy's like here give me 15
[__] grand
and i'll do everything i can this guy
was a bad [__] he wasn't even
jewish but he was like in the circle
like he was an honorary jew when he dies
he's going right to that kingdom because
he had that [__] fruit
and he would tell me how he called a d.a
a [__] i'm getting you and this guy got
me
for 15 000 he got me down to second leg
burglary
an accessory to a felony and they were
both non-violent
he was a genius he goes we're fighting
for non-violence you have no other
violence in your past
i'll [__] erase this i'll erase this
this guy went the [__] work
you know but then i had to go to a
probation thing where the probation
interviews you
and i went in there with that attitude
guys this is where the other end of the
story comes in
in the beginning i told you
[__] there was something good
about it
and there was something bad about it the
bad thing about it was
this poor kid what i put vela through
that day he was tied up for eight hours
in the trunk of a car hungry
you know what i'm saying but he knew the
[__] rules he knew what was gonna
happen you all know once you cross that
line
that's why i always tell people before
you cross that line know exactly what
the [__] you're getting yourself into
because it's different waters
and i was a [__] evil shark at that i
was the shark from jaws at that time i
would [__] eat you alive
it was just in my blood i was angry i
wanted to take down people i wanted to
ruin other people's [__] days
that's what happens when you have a
[__] miserable life and you're sad
and you're
i just wanted to [__] ice somebody so
i walked into this probation office and
i walked in there with the superhero
defense
i didn't do dick this lady looked at me
she goes because i worked this thing i
went to jersey and i called all my
[__] friends i said i need letters
sent to the judge
thousands of them they got me letters
from people i didn't even [__] know
judges politicians
joey diaz is a character he's great i
don't even know these [__] people
priest this [__] lady had boxes of
letters from people
she's like it hurts because the the
motivation is when you go in front of a
judge
every one of those people knows 250
people so the more letters the judge
gets the more people you [__] know
he's gonna think twice about [__]
condemning you because he wants a
political [__] career
so the more letters that people pitch in
he gets scared when you die
you get 250 [__] mass cards because
that's the average of what you know
so that's the way they think they look
at all those letters and they go we
can't [__] prosecute this guy
so the plea bargain was six years
whatever it could be prison for six
years community corrections for six
years
but i could have beat it that [__]
when i was talking to that probation
officer
and i did the one thing that if you
don't do in [__] life you'll never
grow
i didn't claim responsibility i did not
claim responsibility
if i would have gone in there to that
dirty [__] because she was from new
york too she was crazy
oh they said listen i had a bad [__]
day i snorted some blow i woke up and i
went and [__] gang lane this
[__] tied them up
she would have said you know what i'm
gonna give you 90 days because they even
said it
they even like the sykes came in and
they were like there's 90
chance and no recidivism he'll never get
in trouble again
i got everybody involved i paid
psychiatrists i played a public
investigator
i [__] paid out the ass and the
beauty of it was you know what i made
for all that [__] coke
i made eighteen thousand five hundred
dollars
you know what the attorney cost me
eighteen thousand dollars
so it cost me five four years of my life
and
five hundred dollars to do that stupid
[__] day
but if i wouldn't have done that think
of all the things that wouldn't have
happened like yeah i feel bad for tibble
and i'm gonna have to answer the saint
peter when i [__] go up there he's
gonna say dog you got a [__] mark you
kidnapped this [__] kid
what were you thinking catholics don't
act that way
you're following me i'm gonna have to
answer for that i answered for every day
of my [__] life but what i got from
it was
i learned to claim responsibility which
once you claim responsibility that's the
most important
[__] thing in the world anything is
possible after that once you go you know
what
i [__] up i shouldn't have put my dick
in your ass it was dark
i couldn't find the hole sometimes you
where you put it in my ass what type of
savage are you it's [__] dark you
should have just read from the beginning
you're over there playing tough to get
you know because and i sit there and and
i knew i was gonna get locked up and i
[__] trained for it like i lifted
weights i joined the swimming club
i rode a bike i worked on [__]
tightening exercises i heard that [__]
done
you know and it's like my life is so
lucky and
before that i was telling my friend last
week that i even got blessed on the way
into prison because i knew a guy in
boulder
that had been through the system and i
met him my father-in-law was this
insurance guy and he crashed up two
maseratis or something one week
the guy was a coke dealer that was a
computer nerd and just went [__]
crazy
but he liked me and he goes listen he
broke it down for me because you're
either gonna go to rifle or golden
you're gonna go here for six weeks he
goes let me make a call so when you get
to that
diagnostic you're gonna be fine you know
so i was like are you [__] serious
and this guy wasn't a mobster or
gangster he was just a regular white
[__] nerd that liked computers he
knew how to [__]
do all that crazy [__] so
it was so funny because even until that
moment i went to
to sentencing like the whole time i had
kidnapped him
and i went to probation i never claimed
it i kept saying i'm going to get away
with this
i kept snorting blow and [__] lying
and calling long distance on people's
phones and just doing shitty things like
i'm saying i'm going to get away with
this
and i was going to sentencing august 15
1988 and they called me
friday at four o'clock to tell me
community corrections did not accept me
that means that they wouldn't put me in
county jail for 90 days and let me do a
halfway house
that means i was going to prison and the
[__] story i was told on a friday at
four o'clock
and i thought about abandoning ship i
really did my friend had a dealership it
hurts in [__] some country
and he goes i could have gone there and
managed it and came back i had all these
opportunities i knew people
but i [__] also knew that if i didn't
take care of this
something inside of me bro i would have
ran eighty percent of me wanted a
[__] run i'm not gonna say they
didn't lie to you
but that twenty percent was like you
know what bro this is the beginning of
your manhood
and i remember going to that i snorted
coke all [__] weekend
my friends flew in coked up like nine of
them flew in from jersey
monday morning my sentencing was at ten
they got white rings around their nose
they got chicks with them you think it
was like [__] the uh what's that show
uh
beat show with the [__] guidos it was
like that they were all sun tan with
tank tops on and [__]
i got a suit on i'm looking at these
guys and i'm like who's got the [__]
coke they had coke on them they were
still up from the night before
this is how crazy i was i'm going in
front of a judge and i'm like you know
what bro
let me go take care of this and then
we'll go back to the house and party
this is how [__] delusional
i still was up to the park and you guys
see me here i could talk and yell and
all this [__] and i rant and
they mentioned my name jose diaz that's
what why i mean telemarketers call me
and they say jose i don't [__] agree
to nobody if you call me and ask for
jose
it's joey you got the wrong number [__]
click and i hang up
jose is always a bad number right there
for me whenever they say jose that's
never [__] good
i always take a pause so jose diaz i go
up there with
dubois he goes you know you kidnapped
somebody and he read it to me he's like
listen you wouldn't have [__]
gone to jail but you didn't accept
responsibility he goes i want you to go
in there i'm gonna send you to prison no
he didn't even say that at first he goes
i really want you to think about blah
blah blah and i'm still in the back of
my mind going i got this [__]
because i'm johnny charisma
i'll rock and roll my way out of this
one what they call that when you chuck
and jive that's the d.a said to me
he goes you've been chuckling and jiving
all your life it's time to pay the
[__] piper that [__] had me
pinned
and he goes jose did he's got any word
to say to yourself and you guys see me
how crazy i am
i went to talk and my voice went
i was like a little girl i was like yeah
and he goes okay then
and this [__] looked at me goes
get up you ready and i'm like yeah and i
look i remember looking at my buddy's
like watch
this and this guy goes boom
four years department of corrections and
the room froze and i'm like what this
[__] say
and he goes four years d.o.c you're
going away i'm sorry i go
and i'm like these guys got an ounce of
coke i get the attorney go listen talk
to this [__] see if i can stay
out there wednesday or thursday
tell them i got to take care of [__] we
got this the attorney turns around and
goes your honor
joey has to take care of a lot of stuff
is it okay if he gets a reprieve till
thursday this [__] looked at me
goes
boom right now you're going away
everything just [__] went out of my
body
everything just guys you have no idea i
remember turning around trying to like
reach for the coke like
i was falling off a cliff
like it was it that was it and i had my
suit on i went they put me in a cell
with a camera and i'm in there for like
15 minutes
it's getting hot and then i go to take
the jacket off and i go in the pocket
and there's like an envelope in there a
little bit of [__] coke
and i was like oh my god god is with me
again
and there was a camera that went under
the camera and [__] snored the coke
and
passed out passed out from the end of
the stress
i accepted what had happened i accepted
what had [__] happened that was it
there was no going back there was no
mommy
there was no nothing i had to pay for
him and i remember as i was getting in
that cell guess who walked past me
with a [__] mop said well he was a
[__] trustee so he ratted
he didn't he didn't rat against me in
trial at the sentencing
but his uh testimony was the one that
[__] nailed me
he said i had tested my attorney
fingerprinted the machine gun and the
handcuffs and all that [__]
and they found dick so he started
looking bad so
that's what happened but like i told you
guys in the beginning
it was a bad day or it was a good day
depending on you [__] look at
it
you make the call it's what i got out of
because when i went to prison i realized
i could do stand-up comedy
you know i realized a lot of [__]
things and i came out and i still stayed
a criminal for ten [__] years i'm not
gonna lie to you
i'll still shoplift the lighter from
7-eleven if you let me
if you let me just out of gp just to let
myself know i still got it you know what
i'm saying
i'll go in there and get a water when
that guy turns around i'll clip a
[__] light i'll do it as i'm putting
my hand
i reach for the dough i got the lighter
already in my hand that's how bad to the
bone i
am and when i walk out i feel [__]
bad god's going to punish me but i got
to test myself
but that's as far as i test myself it's
not like i'm kidnapping people anymore
you know what i'm saying
that's as good as it gets man so thank
you very much i'm sorry i took you to
deep waters tonight
that's some deep [__] waters like i
said i don't want
you guys to you know
and the aftermath of this is [__]
vela's on facebook and i facebook them
on
every anniversary of the kidnapping i
really do
i swear to god i [__] facebook and
friend request and this [__]
until this date third what is it 2087 97
it's like 25 [__] years this guy will
still and every on november 18th i hit
him up hey cox locker
how you doing and he refuses to forgive
me
and it's funny because i swear to god i
saw him i saw him in 94 at pearls at a
bar on boulder and he was in really bad
shape he was [__] up by that time he
was on heroin
and his face was all [__] up and he
saw me and he came up to me and hugged
me
he's like it was a bad day dawg i even
bought coke from him that night
he's like again and i go just just just
tell me what you got
he gave it to me and he hugged me and he
forgave me because i really forgive you
for what happened
and he was nodding on the heroine and
that night i realized how bad i [__]
up
because this poor kid never really
recovered from it he looks good on
facebook
i look at his pictures and [__] he looks
healthy so i'm happy that uh he changed
his life and it's not funny it really
isn't a funny story
but i had to make it funny for me to
live with it because it's the dumbest
[__] thing i've ever heard in my life
if you told me i did that
20 years ago i would say no i did i
never
ever really and i really thought i was
gonna get away with it i really thought
i was tony montana
that's the [__] scary thing of this
man so
thank you very much for coming any
questions you guys want to answer it's
nothing
you're as mummified as i am i hate
saying the story i'll see you guys
[Applause]
outside
you